No More Mutants
Welcome back everyone this is going to be
my new doctor strange 2 trailer video they
dropped another trailer with more footage
so we'll break it down and it'll be my video
for wolverine the other fox x-men variants
and other multiverse characters from other
fox marvel movies a lot of you asking about a
version of wolverine showing up in the movie
and there have been a lot of rumors about which
characters we'll see is part of this multiverse
illuminati team some of them have been confirmed
with the other promo art so i'll explain those
if you're new to the channel we're doing
a giveaway for imax tickets for the movie
all you have to do to enter is just let me know
who you think plays wolverine if he's in the movie
but this version is not played by hugh
jackman and like a lot of these other
multiverse characters they wind up being
variants from other universes that just look
like the original actors this is actually kind
of funny too because the new trailer that they
release is actually making fun of people who watch
movies on their tiny little phone screens instead
of on imax or regular movie screens if you're
watching doctor strange on a screen this small
you're in the wrong universe it should go without
saying please do not watch movies on your phone
that's like literally the worst possible way you
could watch a movie but there have been a lot of
rumors about which people are on this multiverse
illuminati team the big focus is mostly on the
x-men fox characters because of patrick stewart's
professor x showing up in the trailers but big
reminder that most if not all these characters
are probably variants of the versions that we all
remember like this patrick stewart professor
x is not the professor x from the actual fox
x-men movies that we just got done watching he's
just one of his variants from a similar universe
in a timeline where his professor x joined the
multiverse team the way they explained it in the
logan movie is that the one from the original fox
x-men movies in the future of that timeline wound
up dying during the events of the logan movie even
though the timelines can be a little bit different
from universe to universe most of the people that
we're seeing on this multiverse illuminati team
are from the present day the other big difference
with this version of professor x2 is that in the
concept art you can see his chair that he uses to
float around and looks exactly like the gold one
from x-men the animated series the futuristic
looking one that he actually floats around in
so there also might be some more easter eggs for
x-men the animated series too everybody playing
the theme song in their head right now the chair
from the x-men movies that he typically rolled
around in was a regular electronic chair just
like a normal disabled person might wind up using
if you look at some of the new posters
they just released to zoom in enhance
some of the other concept art makes it seem
like there are seven spaces on the team
in six chairs like an empty space in the
middle for professor x's chair so counting
it off we know there's that alternate professor
x we know there's a version of captain carter
maybe it's the same version from what if played by
haley atwell or maybe it's just from a different
similar universe because her shield is in the
poster so we know that it's a version of her we
know there's a version of mordo he's the one with
the sword walking behind the chairs that's not
blade or anything like that that's just mordo
with the sword we know because of the ultron
robot variants from another universe that look
kind of like ultron bots but they're different
that's the tip off to a superior iron man
variant is like his version of an iron legion
we know about the maria rambo captain marvel
variant i'm assuming that she's probably on
the team because she'd be so powerful it'd be
weird for her to not be on the team if she's that
strong the character to the left here seems like a
black panther variant played by a different actor
but also there's rumors that there's a version of
black bolt from the inhumans from that inhumans tv
show like they're legit gonna do a version of him
and maybe a version of mr fantastic from the fox
marvel movies so there's still a couple question
marks about that last member i'm expecting them
to hold back on this all the way to the movie
actually comes out like they won't fully reveal
everyone on purpose maybe the next couple of
trailers will have a couple clues some of the
concept art when it comes to wolverine and thor
variants it'd be weird if they didn't do some kind
of thor variant during the movie there have been
a lot of rumors that a member of his family that
they have not done in the mcu movies is supposed
to have a cameo and it's supposed to be bruce
campbell's cameo and he'd be playing a version of
balder they almost wound up doing a version of him
during the first thor movie but it just wound up
being too extra there was too much mythology that
they were trying to cover so they had to whittle
down the script that was way back in marvel phase
one when they were more afraid of losing money and
going bankrupt again so they did more boilerplate
types of movies and they saved all the weird
stuff till after they had made their giant
pile of money but even if bruce campbell plays
a member of thor's family from another universe
i don't think that that person would be on the
multiverse illuminati team because typically if
you've seen any of bruce campbell's cameos before
like the spider-man cameos that he did in the sam
raimi movies they're typically comedic i have to
see this show you just let me in i'll stand in the
and i think the idea is they want this multiverse
illuminati team to seem like a huge threat
as for wolverine there have been rumors that
hugh jackman still isn't coming back it's going
to be another variant played by another actor
and if you've ever read any of the wolverine
stories or watched any of his depictions in
the animated series or in the live-action
movies with hugh jackman himself no version of
wolverine is ever really thought of as a huge
joiner like it was a huge deal that he
actually even agreed to be a member of
the x-men team in the fox movies excuse
me i'm eric lynch xavier go yourself
he's not exactly viewed as illuminati material
in the comics the characters that are actually
on the team are typically viewed as masterminds
that are willing to operate in this gray area
do really morally questionable things universe
altering things in the name of the greater good
and that's not really wolverine he does do
some shady stuff along the way he is a bit
of an anti-hero but he's never been a member
of the illuminati so if there is some kind of
wolverine cameo he's probably just going to
show up very briefly and just wreck as much
stuff as possible as you would expect him to
do in a cameo like this like enforcer style
or doctor strange and the others run afoul
of him and he winds up being a huge threat
but when you talk about mutants in these fox
x-men characters actually showing up in the mcu
legit because there's been so much talk
about this alternate version of scarlet witch
blowing up this illuminati base and killing all
these variants my early theory is that during
the movie at some point they'll give mcu scarlet
witch the actual reverse no more mutants type of
scene where she messes the multiverse up so badly
spider-man style she winds up causing some problem
that explains why a lot of mutants eventually
start popping up inside the mcu like during
spider-man no way home spider-man winds up being
blamed for all these multiverse problems i think
it'll be a similar scenario during doctor strange
multiverse of madness with mcu scarlet witch
the funny difference with characters like
ryan reynolds deadpool is that he's such a
meta character you could literally do anything
with his character and just have him call it
out and you're good to go like they're actually
making deadpool 3 right now he could show up in
that movie and say that he's been inside the mcu
this whole time and as long as he makes fun of
that saying that nothing makes sense anymore since
what happened during doctor strange too that's all
the explanation you need for him any tips on uh
getting into the mcu there cork that's part of the
reason why they had the joke about the different
timelines between patrick stewart and james mcavoy
during the first deadpool movie like ha ha it's
all the same timeline none of it makes sense and
it totally worked in that movie so everyone posts
all your theories about how mutants start showing
up inside the mcu if scarlet witch seems like
she's on such a tear to mess the multiverse up so
badly and let me know who you want to play this
wolverine variant if it's not going to be hugh
jackman playing wolverine during the movie the
other new footage that's part of this trailer is
america chavez meeting doctor strange and wong
in the streets of the mcu outside the sanctum
before gargantos that giant schumagorth looking
tentacle creature attacks them with the runes all
over it that also makes it seem like it's being
controlled by someone else who wants her power
to travel the multiverse there's also more footage
of scarlet witch rotating around her as she hovers
inside of what looks like could be kamartage or
the darkhold temple based on the runes around her
there are some fuzzy pixelated paintings in the
hallways behind her that we can't totally make out
but they probably depict ancient magical battles
there are a lot of people that are still asking
who is the actual villain in the movie and the way
they're playing things is actually kind of a meta
idea the whole idea here is that during this movie
doctor strange is supposed to be traveling the
multiverse himself physically for the first time
that's the way that marvel is explaining it in
their official synopsis according to marvel he's
supposed to learn how dangerous the multiverse and
variance of himself other variants can be to the
sanctity of reality this path exacts a heavy toll
okay so for instance sinister strange and
all the trailer footage with the third eye
that we just saw he's supposed to be bad in
the movie they wind up fighting they also
wind up fighting a marvel zombies version of
doctor strange who seems like a good character
that winds up inadvertently becoming bad when he
becomes a full-on zombie the multiverse illuminati
are supposed to be kind of sinister even though
they pretend to be good during the movie and
this alternate version of scarlet witch winds up
doing a bunch of really bad stuff so even though
we all think that mcu scarlet witch is being
positioned as kind of a villain during the film
the whole idea is that versions of them from all
these alternate universes could theoretically
end all of reality they're all that dangerous but
i think part of the idea is also giving you an
actual villain like metaphorical villains and real
villains eventually will come out of the movie
with someone feeling like the actual villain a lot
of people thinking because of the nightmare call
out that it is nightmare himself who is from the
nightmare dimension that was actually the original
director scott derrickson's idea but he left the
project so that's why a lot of us assume that
they would just switch up what was going on with
the villains there's a lot of chaos magic in the
dark hole tied to this in the comics the darkhold
was created by cathode the god of chaos he also
is the person who gave scarlet witch her chaos
magic powers when she was born so everyone let
me know in the comments if you actually think that
legit some other big cosmic evil villain will show
up during the movie and truly be responsible
for everything that's actually been going on
speaking of powerful big cosmic beings we'll
learn more about the mcu gods during the moon
episodes my full moon knight episode 3 video will
post wednesday just like normal make sure you have
alerts enabled for my channel so you don't miss
that everyone click here for my new moon knight
ghost rider midnight suns video and everyone click
here for my brand new thor love and thunder first
look video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!